إذا أعجبتك هذه الوصفة، ليس من الضروري
أن تكون من متذوقي الكعك، يجب أن يكون الكعك
طويلًا حتى تقدر
فطيرة اليقطين، يا جرو، تعال هنا يا صديقي، تعال
هنا،
تعال إلى هنا عندما وجد الراعي الألماني
نفسه غير قادر على الخروج من قناة في
غليندال  أريزونا كانت فطيرة اليقطين
التي أنقذت المضخة نوعًا ما، إنها
فطائر اليقطين الخاصة بزوجتي يا رجل، ما مدى جودة
فطائرها
جيدًا عندما تصنعها، أحصل على قطعتين يوميًا،
الضابط بيل داوني انظر إلى ما حصلت عليه، حيث
ضحى الجراء بأحد فطائر اليقطين الخاصة به
من أجل  استدرج الكلب بالقرب بما يكفي حتى يتمكن
ضابط آخر من الإمساك به
ولعقه قليلاً وتمكن الضابط
حرفيًا من جعل المتصل
فتى جيدًا ولكن عندما أعرب الضابط داوني عن أسفه، فإن
الشيء الوحيد هو أن
الملصقات عبر الإنترنت اعترضت على أنك لم تضيع
كعكة الكعك التي حفظتها  أخبر ضابط البوب ​​اللطيف
داوني زوجته أن الناس يسألون
عن الوصفة، أنا أذهب مرحبًا، الجميع يريد
كعكة اليقطين هذه، إنها
ليبي، إنها كعكة ليبي بوكس،
وأعتقد أنه في فيلم Turner and Hooch
لم ينجح الأمر عندما توم هانكس  حاولت
استخدام فطيرة المافن لتكوين صداقة مع كلب الدرواس
الأكثر ذكاءً
الذي ردد بفكيه حول
حلق توم في الحياة الواقعية،
تساءل الناس هل تمكن الكلب بالفعل من
أكل فطيرة، لسوء الحظ، لم
يصل مالك الكلاب المذهول، لقد
نسيت الكعكة، لقد رميت الكعكة على
أرض يمكن للطيور أن تأكلها، لها
لقب جديد
يستخدم كعكة اليقطين لصيد كلب
لا شيء نصف مدروس بشأن هذه الفكرة كيتي
معظم سي إن إن نيويورك